hi I'm fair and cousins from Ring of
Fire sitting in for David Pakman welcome
back to the David Pakman show a very
interesting development happened at the
end of last week news reports came out
that oil companies are now begging the
federal government for money in order to
protect them from the effects of climate
change these same oil companies by the
way who are in court all over the
country arguing that they shouldn't be
held liable for the damages
that are being caused by climate change
that they've known about for decades
just didn't tell anybody even hit it
from their own shareholders but now
those down in Texas are begging the
federal government to come in with
billions of dollars twelve twelve
billion dollars they want from the
federal government to help protect their
oil refining facilities down there in
Texas from climate change so why now
well as you'll recall last year we had
hurricane Harvey it devastated the city
of Houston Texas and Houston obviously
is a very big oil refining city it was
long along with all the outliers and it
was also horribly flooded flood of the
century they said and then we saw more
floods like that just in the same year
but nonetheless chemicals toxins toxic
waste from these refineries and other
chemical plants in the area we're all
leaked into that water contaminated the
groundwater contaminated the Gulf of
Mexico when they receded into there all
in all really bad the oil refineries
were partly responsible for that along
with the chemical plants but they
understood something that most of the
media wasn't really talking about and
that is that this massive storm and the
massive flood was the result it's what
we get with climate change that's what
happens and they want to make sure that
it doesn't happen again they don't want
to be liable for when the next time a
flood comes and all their toxic
chemicals go out into people's waterways
and the drinking water and
homes in the soil so they want the
government to come in with twelve
billion dollars to create massive sea
walls to help work on water redirection
plans to protect their refineries but
it's not just about refineries obviously
or excuse me liabilities it's it's they
don't want their operations to be
interrupted at all they still want to be
able to refine that oil get it out there
so we put it in our cars we use it to
make plastic whatever it is we need to
do they want to keep supplying that oil
so we keep burning it they just don't
want to pay for any of the the problems
that it causes when we do that and again
I can't stress this enough they are
arguing in courts all across this
country in fact they've had I think
three major legal victories in just the
last few weeks where cities and states
are suing oil companies for the cost of
climate change that those cities are
having to deal with rising sea levels
increased floods things like that the
cities incur the cost which means
taxpayers and they just want the oil
companies to come in and pay their fair
share they did help create this problem
but courts across the country are
actually throwing those suits out at the
request of the oil industry why because
from a strict liability standpoint it is
difficult to say that Exxon is
responsible for X amount of pollution
and that X amount of pollution is
responsible for y amount of climate
change almost impossible to really come
up with those particular equations
therefore liability is impossible to
determine and that's why these lawsuits
are getting thrown out it's sad it's
unfortunate but these oil companies know
they know what they've been doing for
decades they know they've been covering
it up for decades and now they want to
take 12 billion dollars from our already
cash-strapped government to protect
their facilities they also say that oh
this protects the nearby communities as
well because the seawall won't let them
get flooded people need to be protected
from the effects of climate change but
here's the thing we
your industry is already getting
subsidized to the tune of between four
and seven billion dollars every year
from the federal government
you don't really deserve any other
handouts hell you don't even deserve
those handouts to begin with but you're
still getting them so if you want more
money from the federal government that's
coming from the taxpayers if you want
that money to mitigate the effects of
climate change then you can take it out
of those subsidies that you get every
year or and this is just crazy talk the
fact that you're a twenty or thirty
billion dollar per year in profit oil
company maybe you could just take like
half of that for one year and that's
more than enough to cover the cost of
that there you go
I just solved your problem more
importantly you want to solve the
problem stop doing what you're doing
stop producing fossil fuels and instead
redirect your company to become a
renewable energy company instead of
refining oil start building solar panels
instead of drilling for oil start making
windmill turbines redirect your
employees to focus on a new area retrain
them rebrand your entire business become
the leader in that industry but you
won't because nobody at any of these
companies has any kind of
forward-thinking they all want to look
backwards they all want to say yeah
there's still a little bit of oil oh
there's still a little bit of coal over
here in this mountain even though the
coal industry is dying I think I can
scrape some off the top if you give me a
toothpick or something that's the point
we're out folks they are gonna do
everything possible into the very last
ounce of fossil fuel on this continent
is extracted and burned and then once
there is nothing left to refine once
there is nothing left to burn they'll
finally look at it and say okay let's
get started on making some solar panels
then and by then it'll be too late
you'll already have other companies that
came in and started making them and
they've cornered the market now
I'm no economist here but it seems to me
that any one of these massive oil
companies that is sitting upon billions
and billions of dollars in the bank if
they truly want to secure their
businesses long-term future it would be
to switch over to renewables right now
right now the technology exists and with
the scientists you have working for you
with the resources that you have I'm
sure you could make that technology even
better you could become the most
profitable company on the planet and you
could be protecting the planet at the
same time but we do not have enough or
word thinking individuals in any of the
fossil fuel industries to actually put
that idea into practice instead they
would rather go down with the ship
extract the last little bit of fossil
fuel from the planet that they can and
then at that point maybe have a strategy
meeting about how to move forward